megan mccain expecting another bundle of
joy it's amazing having a child is the
greatest thing i've ever done i love it
so much
the former co-host of the view announces
she's pregnant with her second child and
it's a girl making a big sister out of
her and husband ben diminishes
two-year-old daughter liberty i just
think having a baby having a daughter in
particular because i love strong women
and i feel like my parents raised me to
be such a strong woman like i have this
responsibility to like obviously love
and nurture but i also want her to be
strong and prepared for the world megan
tells the daily mail ben and i feel so
blessed that we will be adding a new
member to our family we are more than
halfway to meeting our newest daughter
and we couldn't be more excited it's
beautiful and amazing i was so scared of
having children and i didn't know what
kind of mother i would be i just feel
blessed that i have the kind of life
where i can spend as much time with her
as i can and i just
i don't know i feel i'm really really
really happy right now which um i feel
like i earned because it took me a long
time to get here and also
i just feel really grateful and blessed
and i know there's a lot of women that
don't have the luxury i do to be at home
when you want to writing a column and
doing things like this and i feel really
lucky
over on the gram megan jokes ben is soon
to be outnumbered by girls in our house
three to one this winter and shares pics
of little liberty celebrating her new
role
i hope she's proud of me
you know i hope all the things any
mother hopes
i just didn't think i could love
anything the way that i love my dad i
felt like that kind of pure love was
gone and like it was like something i
experienced it was over now but i love
her even like i mean i don't like to
like gauge love but i love her just as
much if not more and it's this pure
feeling of just she's like perfect like
even like you know when she like spits
up or like i have to change her diaper i
think it's perfect so i feel um like a
cliche but it's sometimes cliches are
cliches because they're true you know
[Music]
you